Speaker 1: Hello, everybody, producer Pat Forde
here, filling in for David Pakman on another
exciting edition of the David Pakman show. Fear
not, David is going to be back on Monday, but for
today, at least on this Christmas Eve edition of
the show, you are all stuck with me. But that's
OK because we're going to talk about a lot of
interesting stuff we're going to talk about.
Build back better. We're going to talk about Joe
Manchin. We're going to talk about all Macron
in the latest COVID surge. So let's get
right into the news. As we know this week,
Joe Manchin effectively killed the build back
better legislation in its current form. The
one point nine trillion dollar social spending
plan is not going to get passed this year,
and it's not going to get passed in its current
form. Manchin went on Fox News Sunday with Bret
Baer, and he told him, Look, I'm just not going to
support this thing. So as of now, it's dead in the
water. Chief among mansion's reasons for opposing
the bill were that he believed it would add to
the national debt. He believed it would further
accelerate the rate of inflation in the United
States, and he just gave this general sentiment
of Look, we're we're spending so much money as
it is right now. We can't possibly afford to spend
any more. So some of this economic fear mongering
stuff that we will often hear from the centrists
and the right wing of this country. Of course,
depending on the circumstances. While Goldman
Sachs ran the numbers and they found that
actually not passing build back better
is going to cost the U.S. economy money
because the spending plan would infuse $60
billion into the gross domestic product. A team of
economists at Goldman predicted that the U.S. GDP
would grow three percent in the first quarter of
2022 if build back better were passed 3.5 percent
in the second quarter and another three percent
in the third quarter of 2022. That's again, if
build back better was signed into law this year.
Now, the estimate without the spending plan
in place because they redid the numbers
is that two percent is going to be the rate of
growth for the first quarter. Three percent is
going to be the rate of growth for the second
quarter and two point seventy five percent in
the third quarter of 2022. And when you line up
all of those numbers, you compare the percentages,
you run the raw numbers. The difference is add up
to $60 billion in economic losses for the first
three quarters of 2022. And of course, it's
probably going to add up to a lot more than that
because it's only accounting for the first
three quarters of the year. And obviously,
the impacts of build back better are going to
extend far beyond 2022. Now, of course, we have to
include some caveats here. Like, for example, just
because we're not going to get the $1.9 trillion
legislation, there's a good chance that we get
something done right. I mean, maybe it'll be 500
billion, maybe it'll be a trillion. Maybe it'll
be one point five trillion dollars. We just don't
yet know what the total is going to be, and
we don't know what provisions are going to get
passed yet. And unfortunately, it seems to be
really up to Manchin and what he wants to do.
But we'll probably see some boost to the GDP
numbers compared to those more conservative
estimates. Second of all, you can never fully
predict what the U.S. economy is going to do.
Sometimes we hear estimates from financial
institutions or government agencies about what
we expect job numbers to be or what we expect
the stock market to be at months down the line,
years down the line. And it's always just a guess.
I mean, you can make an educated guess, certainly,
but you never know until it actually happens. You
can't fully predict the U.S. economy and what it's
going to do. But these estimates certainly do seem
to jive with the reality of the economy and what
we know about demand side stimulus. Because if
you think about it, if you go to these different
provisions in the bill, one of the key provisions
is extending the child tax credit of $3000 or
$3600, depending on the age of the child per year
per child. It works out so that if people have
this extra money in their pocket, they're going
to be able to spend it on things like going out to
dinner or going on vacation or birthday presents
or whatever the case may be. And the same can be
said about the other provisions, too, right?
Because people can save some money on the cost
of elder care or child care or health care costs
or prescription drug costs. And so with that extra
money, people can go out and participate in the
economy and it can be economically stimulative.
So I understand why this conservative argument
will sometimes when the day, because it just seems
so intuitive, right? Like if we just don't spend
the money, that means that we're going to save the
money. But it's actually quite the opposite. And
that's exactly what these Goldman Sachs numbers
show us. And we, of course, know that Republicans
are going to make this argument. We know
that they love to fear monger about inflation and
spending and the debt and the deficit. Of course,
they only do that when a Democrat is in charge.
They don't care so much about these things. When a
Republican is in the White House, we saw that last
year with Donald Trump compared to Joe Biden this
year. I mean, these these things like inflation
and spending, they were all going on under the
Trump administration last year. Only now do they
care about these things. But what's upsetting is
that someone who is supposed to be a Democrat, Joe
Manchin, he also buys into these talking points.
And ultimately, that's going to harm the people of
West Virginia. And it's going to harm the country
as a whole because it's going to cost the U.S.
economy billions of dollars going into next year.